records held the grand opening of their  new location today the first 100 people  got a special goodie bag and were  entered to win a 100 gift card they also  had live djs of course watch for sales  to continue all weekend there we spoke  with the record store president and ceo  today about really the magic of vinyl  it's more than just  a song or a sound there's a there's a  culture there there's an experience  there's something else to it and i think  that's what a lot of our customers  understand  the store has eight locations all over  nevada and arizona as well as an online  store you can find the new location at  warm springs and eastern